Baychester middle school is located in  the eternal section of the Bronx most of  our students are qualified for title 1  which means that majority of our  students are low-income students my goal  with teaching sixth grade science is  primarily focused on engagement because  I feel if students are engaged and  interested they will then want to  continue to study so without that  initial engagement or really enjoyment  of learning they're not going to want to  pursue science at later ages so I do a  lot of hands-on activities I try to mix  things a lot with visuals of kinesthetic  example songs movement body movements  and different ways so that students a  remember the content and also are  engaged and are enjoying being in class